and uh they just kept wanting animals  and they keep bringing them in my kids  want a dog and I'm all for my wife's  like no it's it's brutal they become  instantly the most important part of the  house who the animal the dog  the dog has to be walked the dog has to  wakes up the dog everything all of the  energy goes to the animal it's amazing  they're the the dumbest one in the house  and they get all the attention and you  have to bend your whole schedule for the  animals we had a friend my friend Aaron  greatest argument to not get a pet don't  do it don't do it I'm telling you don't  do it don't end up like me man don't do  it I guarantee you that you will not  think that the love you get from this  animal is equal to is worth the work no  way so you resent your dogs yes